الى ذلك اعلنت جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ان سلاح الجو التابعه لقواتها نفذ عمليه
عسكريه على اهداف حساسه في منطقه ام
الرشراش جنوب اسرائيل بدفعه كبيره من
الطائرات المسيره واكد الحوثيون في بيان
استمرار عمليتهم العسكريه ضد اسرائيل حتى
يتوقف عدوانها على قطع غزه ودعى البيان
احرار الامه العربيه والاسلاميه واحرار
العالم الى اتخاذ مواقف تجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولدعم الشعب الفلسطيني واسناد
مقاومته الحره بحسب
البيان من جهتها اعلنت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه على منصه اكس ان المدمره
الامريكيه يو اس اس كارني اسقطت 14 مسيره
هجوميه انتحاريه انطلقت من مناطق سيطره
الحوثييين دون اي اضرار او الابلاغ عن
اصابات وانه تم تنبيه من وصفتهم بالشركاء
الاقليميين في البحر الاحمر بهذا التهديد
بحسب
تعبيرها